[Music]
hey guys
it's quinn here i usually don't do this
to the end of the video but if you
appreciate my content
please click the like button to help
please youtube's strange and powerful
algorithm
since the exact origin of the sand worms
of arrakis
is unknown within the original dune saga
the expanded dune books
and the dune encyclopedia this video
will contain
a fair amount of speculation though i
will try to keep things
mostly text-based the great worms of
iraq is seem to have always been there
tunneling through the deserts roaming
the deep sands
continuing their non-stop biological
metamorphosis
from sand trout to worm to sand trout
again
but in actuality we know that the worms
were not
always on arrakis frank herbert does not
make this fact
obvious immediately he does not delve
into the
origins of the worms at all in the first
book the reader is left to assume
that they are native to the planet which
they then made their home
it's not until the third book in the
series children of dune
that any light at all is shed on the
true origin of the worms
paul atreides had three children the
first was later the second who was
killed as an
infant and the twins laito and ganema
both twins had been pre-born born with
the memories of their ancestors
in children of dune the two decided that
they must go into the desert
in search of a legendary taboo place
known as chakarutu
lato begins to dream of his father paul
the dreams implore him to explore deeper
within his
inner consciousness that is how we begin
to see the truth about the worms
the sand trout he repeated was
introduced here from some other place
this was a wet planet then later learned
from his other lives
that the sand worms had not been native
to arrakis
eons ago they had been brought to that
place somewhere out there in space
there may have been another arrakis and
yet there was no evidence of these worms
anywhere else in the human universe
if they came from somewhere else as
lato's other memory tells him
then where did they come from the dune
saga dangles this question
in front of us but offers no clear
solution
but there are a few hints about the
beginnings of humankind's relationship
with melange
and the worms of dune in dune frank
herbert often focuses on the cycles of
humanity for long periods of time
and yet the worms alter that cycle in a
key way
not only did melange extend the normal
human biological lifespan
as well as providing various other
physical and mental benefits
the spice melange brought the
possibility for certain humans to become
the oracle
to see beyond the veil of time this was
the power to know the possible fates of
humankind
and shape it as they saw fit the worms
gave humankind the ability to see the
cycle
and break it but what are the long-term
cycles of the worms
themselves if they did not originate on
arrakis
and if there in fact was another planet
like dune
that was home to the great worms where
that world could be
is totally unknown it is also unclear
how humankind came to know of the
mysterious properties of the spice
melange
the mind and body altering byproduct of
the desert worms
according to the dune encyclopedia which
provides somewhat different accounts to
what is presented in brian herbert's
expanded dune books
there are a few ideas of how humanity
came to know
the properties of melange the benny
jesuit had used several other substances
before melange in order to
alter their consciousness and physiology
the encyclopedia states that the guild
planet two pile
was discovered by the aurelian exiles
fleeing ix
according to the encyclopedia an
norma simva made the first journey
through hyperspace
aided by the spice melange the
navigational usage of the spice melange
must have been discovered sometime
between the aurelian exiles departure
from the planet x and norma simba's
journey
the arulian exiles would have had to
have stopped on the then
uninhabited arrakis and a strange set of
circumstances would have had to have
occurred
leading them to discovering melange and
bringing it back with them even though
they would have known
nothing of the substances near
miraculous qualities
its value would have been unknown to
them they surely could not have tested
it in sight too
and we must remember that the exiles
were searching desperately for a home
world
not for a new cuisine if the exiles
learned of the effects of spice
after settling on two pile where did
that spice come from
it seems beyond reason that the society
wrestling with the problem of hyperspace
navigation without computers
would have sent scouts on years-long
real space journeys to remote planets
on the off chance that one might find
some natural substance
of value in navigation no matter how
intelligent and energetic how does a
small
group numbering in the hundreds rebuild
a planetary industry
restore its educational system overall
and regiment its population
redesign spacecraft along revolutionary
lines
and carry out lengthy and numerous
random explorations all in 16 years
that the ixian exiles accomplished the
first four of these jobs
is marvelous that they did all five
is incredible the aurelians accomplished
an unbelievable amount in a short amount
of time
and it seems pretty obvious that they
definitely had help from some
outside group who were already familiar
with melange's unique effects on humans
the next hypothesis that the dune
encyclopedia puts forth
is supposedly more widely accepted
within the dune universe
this hypothesis suggests that the benny
jesuit sisterhood had been involved
before they arrived on two pile
the arulian spent some amount of time on
the world of praxis
iii there the exiles were joined by a
woman named darnis leon shard
she claimed to have been cast out from
the bitter jesuit
but of course would have been a benny
jesuit plant she was a reverend mother
therefore she had likely had her other
memory unblocked
likely during the spies trance it is
suggested here that leon
shard had been responsible for teaching
norma sinva
about the spice if this theory
that the sisterhood essentially created
the spacing guild were true
it would be somewhat fitting considering
that the bini jesuit had a sacred hand
in many of the dealings throughout the
history of the human empire
but it would also mean that the
sisterhood had access to melange more
than a hundred years before the rest of
humanity
which is possible for benny jesuit
secrets run deep
but based on all available evidence it
is unlikely
what motive could the binny jesuit have
had the answers to that question are as
numerous
as the benefits and organization like
the guild may furnish
the genes of intelligent and spacing
guild operations
and organization 635 adventurous people
perhaps one day useful in the breeding
program
an organization tying an empire together
widening the resources of the gene pool
the enormous political leverage that
hyperspace
monopoly would wield still how could the
sisterhood have known
that the exiles would stop on praxis
based on the information
presented in the dune encyclopedia it is
clear that the guild did in fact possess
melange in their early days but it is
not clear how
there is a final thing suggested though
it is presented as
the least likely possibility that
melange was a gift from aliens who
desired the reunion of humankind
after the loss of machine guided faster
than light travel
the dune encyclopedia provides no more
information on this
and there is no further evidence of
alien involvement
but considering lato's statement on the
sand trout being
seeded from somewhere else perhaps alien
intelligence could be a possibility
the worms could have even been
genetically engineered with their
specific properties
after all the fact that they affect the
human mind and body in such significant
ways without having evolved alongside
humans
is odd the idea that the worms were bred
specifically for this reason
fits right in with all the other
selected breeding and genetic
manipulation
that goes on in the series ultimately
the origin of the sand worms remain one
of the dune saga's greatest mysteries
and is perhaps fertile ground for future
exploration
in the expanded doom series if the idea
can be handled properly
hey guys thank you so much for watching
my channel if you want more quinn's
ideas
consider following me on twitter and you
can also support this channel by
clicking the patreon link in the
description
or by making a one-time donation through
paypal
and also guys we're getting very close
to the release of my graphic novel tadia
it is still on sale pre-sale at the
moment you can click the link in the
description
to order if you would like it and there
is also a trailer
available that i edited together myself
thank you guys for watching peace